welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace Helbig this
is very exciting we have Carly Craig
with us today you don't know her get to
know her she's an amazing actress you
might know her from things like Hall
Pass from things like role models and
from the YouTube premium series
sideswiped also get ready to find out
about the time that she teamed up with
Brad Pitt to prank his manager I wasn't
expecting this story but get ready for
this episode of not too deep with Carly
Craig this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by our good buddies at
Squarespace who remind you to turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website yourself and if you
do get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help so head to squarespace.com slash
grace for your free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain you're
here to be here well we're just talking
about internet dating uh yeah I met my
current boyfriend on a dating app that I
was terrified to use that got talked
into by my good friend mamrie Hart to
sign up for cuz she was you know dealing
with the dating app see and I'd never
used it before and it was horrifying but
we like kind of knew each other
beforehand but had never met so that's
the only reason I felt safe enough to
like go meet up with him for a drink
that's dangerous that to me I was like
making all these plans with people and
then finding reasons to cancel them last
minute because I've always had this like
weird paranoia that I'm gonna be
kidnapped at some point in my life like
it could happen I mean heaven so like I
was like signing up for it directly but
so now that your new youtube series
sideswiped is all about the like
misadventures of a girl that's
discovering like dating online for the
first time and this relates to your real
life yeah I
was in a relationship for like 12 years
okay and then got out at 35 and was like
now the dating world is changed and
literally what happened to my friend
memory exact same thing yes because it's
friggin scary because you're like I
didn't grow up with online dating yeah
it is not I feel desperate getting on
there I feel like people are gonna see
me and they're gonna judge me so didn't
want to get on but then was forced on by
my friend Dan co-creator of the show
because he got on and forced me to do
that and yes I went on in swiped on like
everybody I was sort of jumping into the
world to research for an idea that we
had about me being single and all that
most dating okay so you went into it
with like project minded okay yes
project minded cuz I was dating and
there were so many stories already like
on the show in Episode four you'll stake
out this guy that's the crying guy
mm-hmm real guy like a lot of the
stories kind of happened like he started
crying we're making out it was crazy it
was like enough to write about but
because they had changed so much and I
was so intimidated I went on tinder and
then just we swiped on everybody we got
tinder plus like oh my god
probably thousand I don't even know like
so many people and then the first person
I went out with with my fiance we got
the first person mm-hmm I got a lot of
messages and we had a lot of matches
just like on the show yeah but I had
already gone on all he's really bad
dates yeah so my first real tinder date
was I was supposed to go on a bunch and
in fact I was gonna go on like bad wines
on purpose like crazy just to get
stories maybe get kidnapped or something
and and so but then I went out was that
good no and how long ago is this two and
a half years ago almost oh wow yeah
Mother's Day two years ago did how did
you what was the conversation with your
fiance about like I did this because I
wanted to make a show about this right
away yeah what you do not at first like
um we texted for like three days okay
I didn't say anything then cuz I thought
that could be like a deal I don't know
it might go weird like so we went on the
date and I told him almost immediately I
was like just so you know like the
reason I went on was because of this but
you're not
research yeah that's a great line you're
not you're not research that's so funny
yeah I mean you guys must get like free
tinder plus for the rest of your lives
now I paid for it and nobody but tinder
did like after the show after it was
written and we gave them you know some
of the scripts and stuff like that yeah
in marketing and we could use their name
on the show I was gonna ask for any
weird legalese between nine and there
could have been and there was with like
using their logo on the actual show so
you see it would be a different like
you'll see the little thought bubbles
come up over the eyes right the flames
like in the marketing Oh interesting
they got to see all the marketing videos
and so they could have proved that but
they didn't get to see the show first
and so you know it's a lot of people
think tinder like produce this because
it's like a huge tinder ad yeah
especially being on YouTube you always
assume that there's a bigger brand deal
behind something you're watching not
like yes you know the studio is me and
Dan like we you know it was like there's
like nothing behind it we just went to
them after we were already in production
and sent them things saying can we use
your name Instagram you know send them
you know footage to say can we use
Instagram on the show yeah yeah it was
the same as any of those nothing that's
so interesting and you worked like so
much like your resumes and saying like
you've done so much stuff in like
traditional and now even though it's you
know the lines are blurring between like
what is considered traditional now even
on YouTube is it different for you to
put up a series on YouTube and see all
these comments and see people's
reactions yeah yeah you know it can be
really two episodes are free so those
ones it's just fair game to just go
crazy on the comments and so you know
it'd be people that don't even watch it
sometimes that are just like you're not
a youtuber like we're on our channel
like they don't like your original yeah
and so we got a lot of hate from that
but there were a lot of people that
loved it and I think once you get like
episode 3 and all the people that
actually subscribed yeah to YouTube
premium and watch the show like I just
sat down and watched it the comments
were great but the first two and
especially the trailer when it came out
oh my god I was like people couldn't
freaking hate the
show cuz they were brutal it was like I
was kind of reading him to be funny at
first was making me laugh and then I was
like this is funny then I'm like oh wait
now I just stopped yeah it's I still
struggle with where I draw the line on
how much self-harm I want to do but yeah
and how much I want a self love by not
going back though right like I won't
read them for a long time and then I'll
be like I'll stay off the first two
because I feel like those ones can be
the more Bruins they're free anyway are
the ones that are vested interest like I
think they're gonna go from 3 on yeah
yeah so those ones are kind of fun
because I because a lot of the show is
relatable to people I think and so I'll
get a lot of people writing to me but
just the comments to of like oh my god
this is me or this happen to me I love
those ones cuz they're like the reason I
wrote the show is write a lot of it's
personal and so I feel like it's gonna
be relatable because it's coming from a
personal place totally but but yeah then
you get a couple of the mean ones and
then we concentrate on those made a
thousand supportive comments and then
one is like [ __ ] off you like uh I
should [ __ ] off well he was so many
amazing cameos and like you said so many
specific characters that were related to
your real life did you feel weird at all
or dunedin from any of the people in
your real life to kind of document them
in the series at all yeah no you know
because you'll always fictionalize it in
some way it sure about exactly that
person and some stuff is like loosely
based on somebody and you sort of mix
other people into the character so it's
not exactly it and I'm pretty sure that
the crying guy was like drunk when it
happened I think he's like a functioning
alcoholic so he may not even remember
that he did that
no no that's about I'll never find it
he's crying somewhere else right now
happily married I think okay
your mom is a flight attendant hmm and
then your dad plays baseball he did I
mean now he's retired you know but he
played baseball back at the 70s okay
your mom being a flight attendant what
was that like growing up
uh she didn't become a flight attendant
till I was 12 okay so horrible because
it's like stay-at-home mom and then mom
lives in New York a lot right first it
was like I remember she like okay this
is how you do your laundry at like 12 I
was like you know when you have a
stay-at-home mom that like of course
she's a lot like me you know she's very
independent one and probably those 12
years for her were like I can't wait to
get that I should for kids yeah but for
the four kids it was it was difficult at
first yeah yeah then we got to like fly
to Hawaii for free so they made out for
a little bit like your mom take your
daughter to work day or you guys she
took me to New York
and yeah so she worked the flight I went
to Newark with her I'd never been to New
York how old are you when this happened
I was 12 it was like right when she
started it was her first like cuz she
was based in New York so she'd have to
fly to New York to start work and then
fly wherever she was gonna fly Oh shoo
so they had an apartment with like a
bunch of flight attendants that I stayed
in with them life change for all of us
yeah she was really happy and I think
that you know she needed that sure that
job and she always wanted to do it and
she's really good at it so I went there
and I remember we saw like the rock
Rockettes yeah you know we saw the
Rockettes and we saw Aladdin came out in
the movie theatres oh it's telling you
how old a but that must be so fun I'm
sure you treat flight attendants
dramatically differently understanding
exactly how your mom I had no issues
still yeah she's a fly jannat my
stepdads my parents got divorced when I
was like 20 well they've got separated I
was like 20 and got divorced later on
but she might have stepped out as a
pilot so they met flying
that's very bro man yeah I know they fly
around everywhere and they're really
happy and she's license now and so she
play oh okay there's a story there right
that's serious yeah they're really cute
they flew in like a small plane across
the United States together I'm like
that's a movie yeah that's romantic I
would do it you have three dogs I do
yeah okay what are their names
Dylan Molly and Angie I love human names
for dog yes and who is it Angie just
turned 16 I she did yeah did do you
throw dog birthday parties I
Gaber I put a candle in her little food
and that's about it I didn't sing like I
just put she almost burned herself like
smelling it for the ground yeah but no
birthday parties oh okay so she's she's
an old woman she's an old woman but
she's rocking her mohawk and like she I
just called I took her to the vet and
had like the senior test done okay she
passed with flying colors she's like
doing great
she's got Cushing's but she's on meds
like she's just she's living her best
life he's awesome she'll run full speed
at two steps right we have in the
backyard full speed and like literally
lands are facing to the second step 90%
of the time but doesn't stop her from
running full speed every single time
your determination and that's inspiring
so I like I learned stuff from her dog
is gonna really you know truly teach us
some of the greatest lessons in life I
think I totally agree
what like I always wonder one as just
like a you know successful actress I ask
everyone that he's in that world like if
you have any standout like worst
auditioning memories or weirdest
auditioning memories I know we all like
to bury them deep deep down in their
shells and not like to talk about them I
like to block out all the bad but I did
have I did have a commercial audition
that it was my last commercial audition
like literally I had one today that I
still I'm not going I like I told him
I'm taking a break and then they caught
me one for today and I was like yeah I'm
not going so I go to this commercial
audition then my hair was dyed blonde
from American housewife okay and it was
like straightened and it was new for me
the blonde I had family I grew up with
blonde hair and then it kind of got
brown and now the guy looks at me and
he's like and this is after I feel like
I've and this is my 20th year here you
know and I feel like I've earned some
sort of I don't know respect in some way
tons of amazing people you're on the
show like you have to mine this room
though unless I go in the room and he's
just like looks at me and he's like
alright so you know and it's like a car
commercial or something he's like so
when you get in the car but like before
I do it he's like when you look when
you're looking out like just make sure
you have some like depth behind your
eyes cuz you know you kind of have that
like Real Housewives of Orange County
look so and I looked at him and he goes
I looked at him like crazy and he goes
you know what I mean like no no like
you're saying it looked like I have no
depth and I have to act like I have
depth Wow what a guy mean what a nice
man he seems really like he's totally
fulfilled in his daily life he seemed
really happy I mean telling me that he I
think he really enjoyed it I was just
like I'm gonna take a break I haven't
commercially auditioned for like five
years now just because it's the right
thing to do it just someone like the
most soulless people I've met and this
is not speaking for the whole industry
and commercial casting directors I met
some nice ones
yeah and like the spectrum of like them
being so it's like bitter at their job
yeah is um most of them and you try to
rationalize like I wouldn't want that
job either but at the same time it's
like but we're all humans let me do it
first before you say I have no I don't
say it before let's just see we do
another take yeah there's gotta be a
different way to phrase something that's
gonna traumatize me yeah the next year
and I've dyed my hair to be on American
housewife or I'm playing one of the real
house I'm like you're like guess I'm
supposed to look like that but this
hurts because this is me doesn't play my
character correctly on this other thing
yeah ow
but in real life yeah what has been your
relationship now that you're like doing
this youtube series everything do you
feel any pressure to I guess be more on
Twitter and social media and Instagram
and things like that yeah and I don't
feel like I'm great at it but yeah I do
feel the pressure a little bit but yeah
all of us I never cave into it I think
though I like I feel like I should be
doing in fact back when we both did in
My Damn Channel show oh really gracie i
did a show called inside Carly jack and
I met each others on My Damn Channel
really yeah yeah I loved My Damn Channel
I remember them saying to me you should
do like get more like do daily
videos and like watch grace like watch
Daily Grace in cyber that's where I knew
who you were I was watching your show
which I loved
oh I was like I felt this pressure to do
that and I'm like I only did it because
I was contractually obligated forced to
do it because of legalities but yeah
it's so good though I ended up watching
it after that day and I was like I'm not
I can't do it I still struggle with
social media now do ya I'd like how to
present myself on it and like what do I
even want to do with this I'm like also
like an adult now and like ten years
later like what am I doing this am i
getting joy I'm just posing like a dog
picture or like you know I love this I
went to your Instagram I was like yes
percent dogs is my kind of girl I like
that I've totally been told like enough
with the dog pictures I'm like I can't
what am i do those people are so cute
they just die in my camera do you have
anyone that you are you love following
or anyone that's like guilty-pleasure
follow online mmm
I mean I love following funny people I
like Twitter I'm not as active I feel
like I'm not as good on Twitter
sometimes but I like to read people
that's where all my news very political
on Twitter can be yeah yeah no I think
that's really cool and I ask a lot of
actor like there's a lot of actresses
now that I think I get curious about
like where cuz for me I always want to
use a platform with a voice behind it
kind of thing but then it's like how
much is too much in like where do you
draw the line for yourself on that and I
was like so like pleasantly surprises
like look at all this like activism
going on yeah I mean I nowadays
especially I feel really strongly about
everything and I guess that's important
to voice your Taylor Swift you said she
got you know hundreds of thousand people
to register to vote so I think that it
is important to kind of you know like
get that out there and express as much
as you can right if you feel comfortable
so I try I don't think that I'm you know
super political on there or anything
like that just because you know I want
to be but I don't know if I know
everything in order to it you know same
same same but I
- I'm thirsty for knowledge some I was
reading it out moving up on things
do you follow like dog instagrams or
anything like am i follow like noodle
noodle the pit I follow those those I
don't know noodles so cute and I follow
the three pit bulls are really cute I
think it's three pities it's cold okay I
don't know this either oh okay this one
will change your life like wait that one
is three pit bulls that just cuddle with
each other and then on Twitter there's
one that's like cute emergency or
something and it's just cute all animal
things like it's like for me I try as
much as all like express political
things I try to make my incoming things
just be all animal thing a salad yeah
getting along and like a bear and a deer
or friends or whatever like that's what
relationships yes a really sweet spot
stuff like that and dodo dodo is like my
favorite what's dodo the dodo is the
best that one has all you know yeah the
dodo and it's an actual dodo it's a it's
an oversight yeah oh it's all animal
stuff that are you'll cry I'll cry I cry
all the time there's a monkey when where
those monkeys really old I'm sure it's
like an orangutan or something minor
it's a it's really old and like close to
death and and it's this person that he
had a relationship with years ago comes
back because the monkeys not eating
anymore you've seen it it's not eating
anymore and he's like really depressed
and this person comes in that his face
when he sees the human literally I cried
like full-on crying no and then I cried
talking about it later it's a happy cry
because it's sad because the monkeys old
but it's also happy that he's so happy
to see that that's a connection but yeah
he's like you maile with no teeth and
his smile is so big it's just so cute
okay
well we're gonna take a quick break on
that note so I could collect myself yeah
we'll be right back with more of Carly
Craig oh not too deep right after this
[Music]
two deep you would be shocked to hear
that this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace
oh really yeah so surprising nuts we
love these guys they've been sponsoring
us for a really long time and
Squarespace makes it easier than ever
for you to launch your passion project I
know we're talking you know new
businesses showcasing your work
publishing content selling products and
more this is the tool for you with
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website yourself and their powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
anything online and they have analytics
that help you grow your site in real
time everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box and there's nothing
to patch or upgrade ever and buying
domains is simple Jack knows he's done
it
and if you get lost along the way which
you probably won't but if you do they
have a 24/7 award-winning customer
support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
I am among them have multiple
Squarespace sites because they are just
so easy to make humble brag from
designers to lawyers artists to gamers
restaurants and gyms and also Jack
fairies you can turn great ideas into
something real so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain at squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace this episode of not too
deep is brought to you by our good
buddies at care of if you don't know
carob is a monthly subscription vitamin
service that delivers completely
personalized vitamin and supplement
packs right to your door just take care
of fun online quiz which asks you about
your diet your health goals your
lifestyle choices and find out in five
minutes what vitamins and supplements
you specifically need guys it's fun then
your vitamins will get delivered right
to your door in personalized easy to
remember daily packs perfect for a busy
on-the-go lifestyle vegan and vegetarian
supplement options are available to
match your dietary needs and your
monthly subscription box can easily be
modified at any time and grace you've
tried this yeah they send it to me and
it is
personalized which makes you just feel
special when you get a delivery that
you're not really expecting and then
it's like a delivery that sells
suspicion to help but they're like your
overall health
yeah and basically for you specifically
for me it had my name on it and it which
also made me feel more accountable for
like taking the vitamins on a regular
basis but the cool thing is that you
guys can get 25 percent off your first
month of personalized care of vitamins
visit take care of calm and enter graced
your AC e that's take care of dot-com
and enter grace for 25 percent off your
first month of personalized care of
vitamins okay so how you're from San
Diego
when did you start acting I moved out I
turned 18 in June and came here in
August so you did like the cliche like
yeah I'm moving to Holly
yeah I saw Titanic again aging myself
before that I never did a play like I
think I was out I was Alice and Alice
when I'm in fourth grade because we were
told we had to well I didn't care about
acting and then in high school I saw
Titanic nine times in the theater and I
was something clicked in my head if you
read my yearbook it's all about Titanic
and going to be an actress because Wow
after I saw that I had like six months
left of high school and I just couldn't
that was it I was like I'm moving to LA
to go be an actress meet Leonardo
DiCaprio meeting Leonardo DiCaprio what
I was crying so much I'm ever being in
the theatre was so crowded you could
like now with like Ark lot you can pick
your two C's before you know it came out
when I was in seventh grade and girls in
my girls of my grade had competitions to
see who could see it the most amount of
times really because they couldn't go by
themselves so they have to get their
parents to pay for things and take them
there so it was like I think it got into
like the teens with my show in
competitions there's some grassroots
marketing yeah so I saw that and was
just like that's what I want to do and
then graduate it and came right up here
just yeah yeah I want anything yeah that
is nuts okay well so since you've been
here since you're 18 years old
what is one
because I think one of the most
interesting things for people that want
to be in the creative industry is like
set Edeka like being on set is nothing
no one teaches you about ever and I
remember like the first couple of times
I was on set I was just like what dude
where do I go what happened yeah yeah is
there one major thing that you would
give as a piece of advice to someone
that might end up in that scenario I
guess you know I think the biggest piece
of advice is being nice to everybody cuz
so when I did role models it was like my
first really big movie yeah and I
remember the prop guy every day would
come up and give me my engagement ring
and we were playing frisbee like I just
made friends with everybody you know it
didn't really matter or whatever and
they ended up getting me a chair with my
name on it cuz they said to me like
you're they're not used to people being
nice to them as what they said and I
remember thinking cuz I was my first
time on a big set and I was like what
what yeah but since now I've been on a
lot of sets it's true like there's a lot
a lot of people that like it's like high
school yeah segregate you in groups and
like the extras are over here and the
director and the actors are over here
and the prop guys are here and and it
just feels like high school really sorry
so I make an effort to sort of get to
know everybody and know their names and
and on my show I did it you know and I
feel like it changes the set it changes
yeah and people you know will remember
you because you're a human being and
you're being nice and you're not acting
like an actress who's there who's above
them or anything like that and I think
that changes it and it also you know
makes you easier to work with so I think
that's true I also think that's just
like a good life philosophy to say but
it apparently it is not like there's a
lot of [ __ ] actors so just don't be
Nestle Effy don't be an [ __ ]
I think that's a great piece of advice
for everyone uh learn people's names
since you've been out here has there
been a certain person that you've
fangirled over in real life ever get
mean you've worked with tons of people
oh you mean that when I when I worked
with them was I think either working
with them and or just like at a party at
an event or something that you've seen
someone and either like embarrass
yourself or like couldn't even get the
courage to talk to someone oh let me
think I mean this I have to think about
that that's gotta be well I mean I I
worked with not I'm not professional if
I work with Brad Pitt and like a prank
so
he's go on what I just watched the
secret right and when this secret was
big my mom still tells you about the
secret all the time I'm constantly
manifesting I was like and I swear to
God I somebody sent it to me as a link
okay and I watch it and I'm like oh
that's pretty cool think positive it
would phone rings is like 10 something
at night I used to be a waitress at this
restaurant man and wonton in Brillstein
grain okay I think I used to come in all
the time in this guy marker bits from
there called me he's to babysit his kid
a big manager there and he's like hey
what he just finished watching the
secret and he's like what are you doing
tomorrow and I'm like I don't know why
and he's like do you want to do some
improv with Brad Pitt and he's like all
right so he he likes to you know you've
heard he likes to play pranks and stuff
he's he's with them it's the managers
are brill okay yeah and so he goes his
manager is gonna help him and Angelina
find a new assistant so we you come in
as like a fake fake interview and just
make up whatever character you want but
just be horrible you know what I mean oh
the manager like who it what is she you
know like what tell me who she is a
little bit and the only thing that they
told me that I really took from it was
that she's like huge into like rescuing
dogs and like you know we drive no
street and like save a dog in the middle
of she's just a big big big on that in
the weekends she's always at shelters
and so okay so I go in the next day and
like flatters this was just a personal
break this wasn't filmed or and it's not
filmed oh my god but you could probably
ask but I have a letter from Brad Pitt
saying thank you for that yeah so I so I
go there to Brillstein and like I was in
love with a Brad Pitt like Louie yeah
you know what I mean and so I'd flat
ironed my hair and I was a very blonde
and I so flat iron straightened was
wearing a pink tube top and like a tiny
skirt oh my heels and I had a purse with
like a disposable camera in it and like
some pills like prescription pills and
like 12 pieces of gum in my mouth oh I
see you Brad and like this is I like I
said I work with I've never I don't know
what he said like like I'm just thinking
oh my god
I'm talking to Brad Pitt this is this is
the only time that's the first time
you've ever seen him in real life yeah
never seen real life so I walk up he's
like perfect and so the whole thing is
the whole thing is to like I'm gonna
meet with Brad Pitt first like however
long that this is what they're doing
with the assistants you meet with Brad
Pitt uh-huh alone and then you meet with
his manager okay the assistant and then
another guy there who was in on it so
I'm it was Brad and I'm like all right
this is I had a flip phone then and I
had a really crazy ringer on it that
would go it would go like her ring and
they would go call from and it was my
friend Miranda going this really
annoying ring and I told them I'm like
call me in the middle of our meeting and
that ringer is gonna go off and I'm
gonna answer it
whenever she's talking about he's like
that's great and then so we talked for
like seriously like 10 minutes I
remember that part I don't remember most
of our conversation I was like this is
what I was doing I was like staring at
people gonna ask me looks like they're
gonna be like what is this hair like and
what is how tall is he so I'm just
studying him as he's talking to me like
I'm such a weirdo in this moment cuz I'm
not like that with anybody
yeah but completely outer-body
experience in that moment cuz it's Brad
Pitt so we have fun we're talking about
it he's excited for the prank and then
he leaves and she's supposed to come in
uh-huh and I'm sitting there chewing my
gum and like popping bubbles and like
spinning the gum and my finger and she's
taking forever to come in I think she
sees me and is just like nervous about
meeting me and so she finally comes in
with her assistant and with the guy
that's in on it and I told the guy to
ask me about dogs right yeah because I
know she's a doctor's so we're talking
for a while and she sees my resume and I
put on some fake resume that I was
Heather Locklear's nanny relax this is
before Heather Locklear went a little
bit crazy yeah yeah at the time she read
it and it calmed her down she's like oh
she's had that luck there's nanny she
must be normal so she's like okay start
to ask me questions I started off
totally normal and then the guys like I
got its in on it he's like so Carly you
know Brad Angele of it the kids and then
they have dogs and stuff how do you feel
about that and I was like I [ __ ] love
dogs and I go like made an effort to
cuss as many times as I can interview
like a [ __ ] love dogs my parents when
we were growing up we had these two
golden retrievers these pure breads and
we just like bred those
and neither one of them had to work we
would just sell him and he was so great
because we'd all stay home as a family
these dogs she was like to her credit
she was so nice to me I could tell she
was horrified but she never said that
he's horrific you crazy person like
nothing because I'm just talking about
it so innocently right and so did that
and I think I told her that I give baby
massages
other than masseuse and I told her you
give massages to babies or you give baby
like I feel like Angelina and I are on
the same size and I'm sure she gets like
lots of free clothes sent to her and
stuff like it was in charge of that and
she's like what do you mean who's in
charge of that I'm like well who takes
care of that and she's like nobody I'm
like that could be one of my jobs
finally at the end I just said like
window a star and she wanted her to me
and I just kept talking but she starts
grabbing like Brad's helmets in the his
bike helmets in the middle it's just
grabbing everything off the table and
her arms are all full I don't know I
think she just was like there's nothing
left to talk about and I'm just I have
to get all these things and go it was my
she leaves I leave I leave I knew Bernie
because he had come into the restaurant
that I've gone into and eventually this
was the beginning of me signing with
them oh this was like you know cuz they
all heard about it yeah cuz she went
into the room and asked Brad you know
like how what do you think it's Brad
like I thought she was pretty great and
she says yeah if you want to [ __ ] her
you know so she's like yeah if you want
to [ __ ] her and he's like really I
thought she was pretty great and so oh
and my phone rang in the middle of it -
perfect forgot about that so while we
were taught she was talking Brad had the
assistant out there call me and it went
and I'm like hold on one second I need
to get that so I answered the phone and
it's her saying something like are you
at the Starbucks where are you and I'm
like I'm in a meeting I'm gonna have to
call you back and I hang up and I said
to her I'm like as you can see I'm
available 24 hours a day seven days a
week the whole day so the entire day
she's talking about this crazy girl that
came in chewing everything that I wanted
her to see she saw the pills you know
she saw the camera she brought up all of
the things in all the meetings and so
the next day he sent me a thousand
dollar gift certificate at Barney's and
a little letter oh man I was like thanks
for the great laughs and performance Wow
pretty cool so that was the time when I
felt that way I was like yeah that's a
very specific start what an insight into
Brad Pitt's life that that he's got
enough time to just like have
shenanigans like that I'm not filmed I'm
like I wish that it was filmed I
honestly thought I was like was this an
episode of Punk'd I just don't know yet
oh my god that is so insane yeah that's
so crazy
I mean how have you not been cast in a
movie with him now no I feel like
haven't run into him since then we got
to talk about how long ago was this Oh
like mm probably five or four when did
the secret come out it was like then oh
okay yeah cuz I was they sent me a link
was like before even people were going
critias like right when the secret
people are talking about it well I mean
what a big plug for the secret and yeah
because what was funny is I had this
like list of people I wanted to work
with or things I wanted to do and he was
number two who was number one
it wasn't like a person it was like
goals and life and one of them was like
work with Brad Pitt and so done that
shit'll I gotta find that list and see
what else has been now checked off right
yeah so maybe we all need to watch the
secret again I'm learning holy [ __ ]
that's pretty incredible it's funny okay
now that you're doing this like series
about dating and tinder stuff are you
getting a lot of messages about people
that have like either experienced this
or like any relationships up are people
asking for like relationship advice and
things like that I
I've gotten that and then the show like
even though the kickoff of the show is
definitely the dating thing and then
when it really gets into it like my big
thing of the show is really about you
know these three women who at the
beginning are where they are and kind of
their growth and who and who they are
becoming right you know getting to know
yourself before you you know before you
let somebody in right is the big message
which is the opposite of what you think
I think from these fights it's like a
romantic comedy where she meets a guy in
an older and they get me which is what
happened to me but so I get a lot and I
wrote a lot about like the gynecologists
office happened to me yeah the opening
scene yeah we Sudeikis I went to the
gynecologist and had I thought girl
doctor was coming in and then like
seriously
forty-year-old gorgeous model walk cuz I
have yeah that's what hooked me right
from the start is that that's my I
always go to a female gynecologist so
that's my fear yeah no one thought that
somehow she's gonna be like sick one day
and then someone's gonna have to replace
their and I was like oh my god this is
my inner fear happening to someone else
it was terrible and the nurse really did
forget the thing while he had the
speculum in there and I was just like in
the moment I'm like what are we gonna
talk about he's gorgeous and I don't
feel like close up ready right now and
like it was just like so I left like
half my brain was horrified the other
half was like I think this is the first
scene of the show because I hadn't
written the opening scene yet I knew I
wanted it to be something yeah you know
relatable and like that and a shot game
but also fully relatable yeah that's so
nuts okay what's the worst way if you're
getting like any of these kind of
conversations with people in terms of
relationships that you've heard someone
broke up with their significant other I
mean I think I think the texting is
pretty bad just to send a doc saying
we're breaking up which I've heard of I
think that's pretty horrible yeah if
you're in a relationship yeah that seems
pretty insincere yeah pretty much like
you're not actually a human being in it
yeah but you're just literally maybe
it's worse if you find out like that
they're cheating or something and that's
how you break up like that's pretty bad
too yeah
double down the hole terrible
I'm terribly okay what's the most
tedious errand or chore that you'd like
to get rid of in your life routine the
dog feeding is it's like so we give him
the honest kitchen
oh yeah it's like ha it's like making
oatmeal like you're so hot three looking
for your dogs and I have two senior dogs
one 16 and ones 10 so like they're all
in meds yeah supplements so Dylan the
the pit bull who's only three but she
got like hit by a car or something
before we caught her so she's got like a
messed-up leg so they're all on
something so the morning routines to
feed these dogs is like tons of just
like putting supplements into their
three bowls and like it's the whole
thing but if I could find a way to to
make that three seconds or like if they
could figure out how to feed themselves
that would be great just Wolverine
themselves and fully heal themselves
i'ma Nanji the older one I have to like
watch her eat cuz she takes so long and
her back legs legs like slide while she
have to like stand there and wait for
her to finish the other dogs don't steal
it and then she always leaves a little
bit tough to spoon-feed her at the end
it's like a whole 10 15 minute thing
they'd have to do every day
twice a day that's very sweet of you my
fiance does it - so he's helpful but
it's uh I think we both would would like
them to just figure it out screaming
figure it out yeah and they probably I
do but they haven't done it yet so I'm
hoping okay like your character in the
show are you one of those people that
needs or wants to be carded at a bar
yeah I mean is that have you had the
experience of someone not carding you
when you feelin yeah mm-hmm I've had it
record somebody in front of me or with
me and then not me and I'm like what's
that about like why not me tell me what
about my face is giving away my hair and
what about her face is making her seem
so yeah please I need to know um yeah
what are your favorite and least
favorite parts of like Hollywood Los
Angeles because I feel like that's also
what this show kind of encapsulates like
this whole idea of like beauty you know
the getting older or younger or whatever
it might be yeah I mean I love Los
Angeles I the traffic sucks
but I try to just not ever drive in it
you know thank you for being here today
we'll see how going home um so I think
that's probably the worst thing about
Los Angeles is just getting around
anywhere takes so long yeah
but the best thing there's so many I
mean like you can live in a place like
I've chosen to live somewhere really
quiet that is ten minutes away from
everything that you need yeah where it's
loud and fun bars and restaurants and
all that stuff but you know that's the
great thing is you can kind of pick and
whatever style you want to live in it it
exists here yeah yeah yeah and if you
surround yourself with good people like
you don't deal with the thing that
people say la is like the people are so
fake and all that my friends aren't I
don't deal with the fake beat the
traffic so it's great I don't understand
what your problem what's your take on
like party scene la like going to events
and things like that
I they can be fun but I like getting
dressed up and everything for me is a
little bit annoying yeah you know just
like even just like I love being at home
watching something great yeah literally
same everything to do so very much once
I get there it's usually fun yeah but
the idea of going every single time I
always because I have to have a
publicist through you know up with the
show and I'm sure and all every one of
the events I'll just be like do I have
to put it this one like how important is
this right right right
so tell me one to ten yeah like if I
don't go is it gonna be a big deal right
what do you watch all kinds of stuff so
like I'm watching Babylon Berlin on
Netflix which is awesome but what that
is really good I highly recommend it but
then I it's but it's subtitle you like
be in the mood yeah dungeon I love Game
of Thrones finally watched all of it big
huge fan my fiance got me into and I
watched it all we was benched you know
in my was like two years but then I love
watching like the Real Housewives and
okay let's go down this wormhole
yeah actual favorites and bachelor in
paradise
you who are your in a safe space
literally all I try to figure out how to
talk to people about what's your
favorite guilty pleasure franchise I
call them guilty pleasures but honestly
I have to stop
because they're just pleasures to me at
this point I agree yeah we don't think
of and if I'm parole this is my favorite
really yeah okay because we had Stassi
on an episode here oh you did and it was
like watching this loading Venus walk
into the room and I was like so nervous
about it okay
yeah more nervous than anyone that's
come on like that is actual like helpful
to humanity by the way I went to sir yes
when she was working there and she was
my waitress and I have to say she was
awesome
yeah she was a really good waitress she
was so cool when she was here that I was
like oh right your people very
self-aware that like this is her job you
know that she is a reality star because
like I really appreciate this kind of
like acknowledgment of like where you
are in the world of entertainment okay
what do you predict for this upcoming
season uh I don't know like our Tom and
Katie gonna try to have a kid soon
hopefully I know Jax and what's-her-face
get engaged brittany.brittany get
engaged because they've let them the
cool thing is they've let them use their
social media now like more in real time
right right so they all hang out with
each other all the time either engaged
like the Jax thing to me is crazy the
whole show is great I mean like all of
them like that's why I love it so much
Lisa Vanderpump for being such a savvy
businesswoman wanted to start these
restaurants then to to go I have a
reality show for you Andy Cohen totally
here we go Tom Tom not yet me me there I
went on Yelp though just to check it out
instead of you doing I think Jerry
O'Connell left a review on it of course
eat it because he's got a show on Bravo
yeah yes Andy Cohen was like go to Tom
Tom
in contrast the inner-workings all go
together oh I'm so glad you love those
shows makes me sad because like when I
get home and there's a really good show
on the DVR like that I probably should
be like oh like I said I've to be the
mood to watch the other like a game of
Thrones or something yeah be like I'm
going to watch Game of Thrones even
though I love it when I'm in ok I can be
anywhere anytime any day and if I see
Vanderpump rules on my DVR I am watching
it getting ready I am like every second
that I can get in on that I'm in right
now I could not agree more
okay well speaking of real people we're
going to take another quick break and
then when we get back we have Internet
questions for you something we're
familiar with you know Jack for many of
us the day does not start until we get
that morning energy boost you know what
I'm talking about I think you're talking
about coffee yeah yeah now there is a
new way to enjoy your daily cup of joe
thanks to cafe monster available in
vanilla mocha and salted caramel cafe
monster is shaking up the ready to drink
coffee category with indulgent gourmet
coffee that's only 190 calories and not
to mention with a hundred and fifty
milligrams of caffeine from coffee beans
B vitamins and coffee fruit extract cafe
monster offers a simplified energy blend
that contains a third at less sugar than
the leading national brand
in fact it's 100 fewer calories per
bottle in the competition but you'd
never know that by tasting it instead
you get all the same feel and flavor as
your local coffee house and you don't
have to wait in line you don't have to
interact with other humans and they've
got three great flavors as vanilla
there's mocha salted caramel Oh
fantastic mocha is my personal favorites
it does taste like chocolate milk I
could be a vanilla girl on certain days
but they're all I mean they're to me
it's just delicious wasn't it give it
give it a shot try it out cafe monster
chill it down shake it up enjoy this
episode matcha deep is brought to you by
Poshmark instead of buying new things
head to Poshmark to shop from millions
of closets across America listen to this
Poshmark is the easiest way to buy and
sell fashion items you download the free
Poshmark app to shop from tons of brands
across
woman's kids and men's you won't believe
the deals you'll find like Louis Vuitton
bags for $300 that's nuts
that's crazy and shipping is super fast
and easy for both the seller and buyer
and is handled all through the Poshmark
app when you see something that you want
simply make the seller an offer and you
can get the item that works at a price
for you need to clean out your closet
listing on Poshmark is easy upload
pictures of your stuff to the app set a
price and then ship to the lucky buyer
no more waiting in line at your local
thrift store just to leave empty-handed
so grace as you know I have a problem
with jacket I buy too many JAC you have
a lot of jackets I wasn't gonna say it I
have like 7 leather jackets and you know
this app has been great for just
perusing and yeah you don't do a store
to store it's all in the app you can
peruse whenever you want also for me
it's the one that constantly gets rid of
like clothes because she's bored with
them I don't need to constantly take it
to Goodwill I can actually make maybe a
profit off of there you go get some of
that money back yeah today you can get
five dollars off your first purchase
when you enter the invite code not too
deep when you sign up
just download the Poshmark app sign up
and enter the code not too deep all one
word for five dollars off your first
purchase okay now that we've just had a
fold to our discussion about every
reality show you like so much we're
gonna get into some Twitter questions
before we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I asked every single podcast
guest and the first is who alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti act cold spaghetti mmm-hmm
like I don't know maybe like Hitler or
something throw some cold spaghetti at
him yeah he sucks I think that's very
fair answer for that
exactly the other question has every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or like a close
call scenario but you can only use three
words or three small phrases or kind of
a variation so mine is college jogging
front lawn okay
mine is oh I like that you already
immediately have one that's my favorite
thing there are some people that have
been on the show that don't have
anything and I just think they're lying
babysitting no extra pants great Oh No
oh but you at least in that scenario you
couldn't blame it on the baby
I can't was really young you know I was
if there the cameras in there cuz I'm
like oh yeah yeah well no more follow-up
questions okay
now into these Twitter questions I think
I know the answer to this but someone
wants to know do you ever cry while
watching dog videos online oh yeah we
talked about that this is so in your
brand yes have you know me that person
yeah have you ever posted a video of
your dog or dogs that you're like this
is gonna go viral this is perfect it's
gonna get everyone no not that I thought
they're gonna go like every one of them
I'm like this is adorable but no ID or
do they have any specific behavior that
they do that you're like this is great
Angie she does this thing when she eats
that she has to put her nose on the
ground like three times and don't touch
her bowl and Benny she's got the OCD
yeah she's crazy now people will see it
someone to know who is her go to Mario
Party character my Mario Kart like the
game I get I think so maybe Yoshi okay
dinosaur I didn't know if this was
something you're into you play video
games uh
I mean I have I'm not like a huge gamer
but um but I used to play some Mario
Kart and I like to Yoshi there you go
what is your she a dinosaur a dinosaur
definitely dinosaur and gender-neutral I
was thought of him as a boy yeah I think
he's a boy yeah I don't know why he was
like oh he's kinda like a horse that
Mario would ride around baby though
right he does seem young there was a
baby version of him - oh she may be oh
she is so cute strange eh you can just
based on graphics think that something
is younger than it is yeah yeah yeah
you're like I don't know why is he so
baby like to me
wrinkle-free supposed to know your
favorite zombie-killing weapon I lost I
watched a lot of Walking Dead and I like
just the the knife right in the middle
of the forehead off of that is there a
show or a movie that's like on your you
know the secret if you will list of
things that you wish that you could be
part of yeah Titanic zombies I don't
know how that hasn't been made yeah I
agree
where they all rise up like frozen out
of the water and the band still play I
don't know how there hasn't been like a
Walking Dead Titanic presence on the
crossover and if there is we're
manifesting it we're putting it out and
I would like to executive produce please
yeah if we get Brad Pitt in it since
we're buds yeah you really are super
buzz someone to know what's your
favorite kind of smoothie it's the very
Los Angeles question oh I don't know
kind of basic
what's your I would add on time acai
berry in it what's your cliche Los
Angeles like Hollywood thing that you
can't help but like do on a regular
basis Luton free that's not like a
choice that's like a body thing well it
still it's baby before it was popular so
people would roll their eyes at me all
the time and it's not like a stomach
thing for me it makes my skin break out
okay I like tested a while ago and
people don't like to do that it's why
it's beautiful
no no my skin my stomach's fact oh yeah
yeah you should try gluten-free might
change your life that's a very L
anything for you to say like you're like
I was gluten-free before it was popular
but why I'm very thankful that it's
popular because all I
could eat was like rice bread before was
yeah eating a brick now there's all
kinds of great things like any I kids
it's really easy to be gluten free now
there you go mmm-hmm but I mean get
yourself checked guys get yourself
checked someone to know what's your
favorite way to waste time I would fully
agree with that I think that's fantastic
would you ever be on a reality
television show no no hard and fast no
hard and fast now that's like a very
responsible answer I think about it
sometimes and I also feel definitely no
and then I wonder if I'm ever gonna get
to that part of my life where it becomes
a maybe and I'm not gonna judge you if
you go on one this is what I wouldn't do
it if I am right if I'm playing these
characters I think it's harder to
believe them if you see me as a huge
like you yourself yeah also if I'm on a
reality show I'm gonna have to play into
whatever whatever they want me to be
yeah bad yeah I'm have to go you know
and it's gonna really hurt you see me as
whatever else yeah so I guess I was
gonna ask too earlier like do you have
you ever like posted YouTube videos or
done anything in that world before
having this series on YouTube of just me
I mean because I do have two videos and
stuff of things that I would write in
like comedy thing yeah like any of that
I did a lot of that yeah I did I would
write these songs and they were all like
naively disturbing you know really
[ __ ] up songs and I'll shoot these
videos and I would put those on YouTube
and and Funny or Die and everything oh
that's awesome like I did Judy Garland
having an orgasm for people that still
your range is amazing
oh I mean I say bring it back it's
timeless yeah Wow okay are you into ASMR
what's what's ASMR what is that stand
for auditory sensory I don't I can look
it up it's basically those like whisper
videos the people be in the
I'm not injured either it's a very huge
genre of YouTube I listen to Howard
Stern and he had a whole thing about
that I didn't know it was called that
but yeah playing them and I don't get it
yeah no I'm with no judgment that's a
lot of like no I'm yeah called
autonomous sensory Meridian response
yeah
rolls off the tongue all the time yeah
but I guess it's supposed to relaxes
people make some people to get like a
stinging sensation yeah I guess
yeah similar to like meditation exercise
massage like getting getting like you're
like you ever get like that tingly
feeling when someone like rubs your head
yeah yeah oh yeah I can give myself
chills just scratch in the back of my
neck so maybe I would be into this these
people get that just from watching these
videos yeah okay someone wants to know
what's your first sona and then I had to
look this up and it's based on the furry
documentary about the furry fandom and I
was like is Carly into furries what's a
furry I might be what is we're educating
you or is it like a furry my very
limited understanding is it's people
that like to dress up in like almost
like mascot esque furry animal not
almost actual mask only like mascot asks
like head to toe furry animal costumes
and they have conventions
and it's sexual gratification I have
been on Howard Stern did you do an
interview on Howard Stern I didn't okay
but he I think he talked about this too
yeah yeah it's I don't know that it's
all sexual gratification though okay I
also I'm so ill-informed on this entire
topic so I am not the person to speak to
exactly what the dressed up like that in
this that was I think the
original like misconception about it I
think like the same with like bronies I
remember that's the my little pony guys
yeah so I think it's more of like a
community of people that enjoy this I
think some of its sexualized I have no
idea guys let us know yeah but I know a
Carly
which one is which one is my persona if
you had a first sona which I guess is a
fairy persona I don't know I'm sure
there's like maybe like a unicorn one
you'd be the Phillie Phanatic no I'd be
gritty he's got the best PR person I've
ever seen ever I've never seen a mascot
in my life ever going this many
late-night shows is horrifying but he's
great I saw this video of him having a
dance-off with a Philly Phanatic they're
friends fanatic dance is classically he
dances modernly it's all canon it's very
exciting yeah it creating a cage if I
could do some research on these furries
I could come up with a better answer I
just need to do a little research I mean
I'm saying season two yeah I know you
see some personalities in these costumes
and men I'll decide okay someone wants
to know what is your second favorite
dinosaur oh well let's see what's my
first first okay may-maybe a
Brachiosaurus well oh yeah I like the
Brachiosaurus what's that good favorite
- the Triceratops okay yeah Triceratops
is really great you like the Triceratops
boy I think they're great they look like
they're wearing like a big like I don't
know like Queen Elizabeth II saying like
yeah yeah the Elizabethan you know it's
very cool this is a great like in Los
Angeles questions what's your favorite
way to park I'm really good at parallel
parking are you really yeah yeah
humblebrag and backing up into a space
you're one of those people it's my dad's
fault I used to make fun of him but I do
it yeah you bunk your bar up into a
space what mm-hmm
I watch people do that and I'm just like
my guy I'll tell you why
okay it's easier to get out I understand
a UPS driver it's like this is how you
park it's so much easier so it's
ingrained in me I can't well it's like
in my DNA I think I get perturbed
because I'm jealous and I wish I knew
how to do it now right changes
everything it does unless you still
don't have like spatial awareness that's
kind of where I'm limited in my car but
no not it used to be when I had a tiny
car I have a slightly bigger car now and
I'm just like everyone is safer away
Carly we've reached the end of the
episode but before you go we give every
guest for giving us some other time a
personalized fortune cookie so this is
just for you you feel free to open up
you do not have to eat it I don't think
it's gluten-free there's a long one yeah
oh wait someone out there is not figured
out that sideswipe is not in fact the
new Shane Dawson docu-series we hope
they figured out soon but they like the
show nonetheless this is a great fortune
where can people find you online where
can they find sideswipe if they don't
know everything else that you're working
on yeah so sideswipe does on YouTube
premium so you just you know we could
first two episodes are free and then you
can download or you can subscribe you
get one month free so you can watch all
eight amazing and then do what you want
after that
there you go Benji Benji yeah and
American housewife I'm doing that on ABC
I'm going back for season three awesome
just shot it last week I'm on Instagram
Carly see Craig and I'm on Twitter Carly
underscore Craig and then Facebook
okay perfect well thank you so much guys
go check out sideswipe did you haven't
already and like you said like Harley
said you can sign up you know binge it
and then get out of there do whatever
you want to do just I mean if just
saying it's up to them to keep you after
that you know what I mean it's up to
them Thank You Carly thank you guys next
time on another episode of not too deep
goodbye too deep too
Oh deep deep calf a monster is shaking
up the ready to drink coffee category
with indulgent gourmet coffee that's
only 190 calories available in vanilla
mocha and salted caramel with a hundred
and fifty milligrams of caffeine from
coffee beans B vitamins and coffee fruit
extract in every bottle Cafe Monster
offers a simplified energy blend that
contains a third less sugar than the
leading national brand but you still get
all the feel and flavor of your local
coffee house and guys when I'm telling
you these are delicious I mean it the
mocha tastes like chocolate milk it's
dangerously dangerously delicious cafe
monster chill it down shake it up enjoy
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor melissa demons writing by Diane
King production assistants by Katrina
Henning post-production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]